all right so
um
this is either going to be really good
or really bad
so
um and usually a talk should you know uh
give you not only knowledge but emotions
and
and laugh and cry probably gonna be a
mix of things
um but if you see anything going wrong
The only positive side don't cry and uh
um because
um now that we're back into going in
person and doing conferences and stuff
uh less couple conferences I talked
I've noticed a lot of people were mainly
having slides and I usually had this
tendency of overdoing and it's going to
be a very Hands-On very live coding
session uh well
code that runs live
um I'll live code just a little but um
so there's a lot that can go wrong so
uh be ready
um and for the enjoy
Ed like enterprisey headshot it looks
really
um so first of all before starting I I
really want to know more about you and
uh you know
what do you do what are the demographics
uh
why you're here and all of that so I'll
start with a few questions uh how many
here are data scientists
okay less than expected uh how many here
are python Developers
awesome and I see overlapping between
the two
um
who here has more than 10 years of
python experience
wow congrats
um
more than 50.
okay
oldies yojis
um
so how many here has have less than one
year I
thought cool welcome
I I'm you know if it's not your first
conference or if it's your first
conference welcome
um I don't hope misses are amazing so
it's probably not going to be your
life um
who's here
to learn something new
we're here hopes to get
a new job
nobody nobody will tell yes is your
employer in the room
foreign
so
um
who here is expecting to go out of this
conference with new friends and new
people that can't help
a job or just an accident
okay also dude and to be honest that's
honestly my experience in conferences at
this point
um
I'm old enough to say like
I've been in a lot at a lot of comments
today I really think the best part of a
conference is but social and talking
with people and getting to know what
they're doing and connecting ideas and
things like this so I highly encourage
encourage you to do that and even if you
miss five minutes of the talk uh cherish
those connections
and meet new people
who am I
um I'm a software architect and Anaconda
a reader of high script
um and I've been in the python ecosystem
for
all the community stuff uh
especially in Europe
early 2000s
2010s and then moved to the US recently
and
I want to start this talk with a little
bit of
context in history
um
who here is familiar with this
chart
cool
um
what is it basically it's an index of
popularity or different
types
yogis in the room
you can see that
there wasn't a very different spot
s which
arguably is the most popular
fight
and python has a very
unique
and started really as a
weekend project or something along those
people get into programming it became a
thing
and you can see
the air
the charge you can see
the point where
reflexes
Google he became way more popular
companies started saying oh what's the
thing now maybe we can allow this
program
like especially for large degree at that
time I remember
having a really hard time to actually
introduce python because
and then through a history Pipelines
of exploding for specific verticals you
know it became super popular for devops
and so increased popularity
is that the area of
web Frameworks
theater
and actually learning and deep learning
Ai and
um
but one thing
that I think is for to python is that
a lot of people say you come with the
language you stay for the community I
think it's one of the strengths of
fighting
very social and
you can
you can if you have problems if you
show people and you know I really
encourage everyone to feel that and to
contribute and use that too
but it's also weird how's it possible if
you think about it python is
not great for the mainstream
Hardware
and software today you cannot run well
easily the story of python or mobile or
tablets it's a non-existent right or is
an ethnic one
thing for the most
ubiquitous operating system in the world
which is the browser
arguably
python just
doesn't really run on the browser
nicely
so well that's when
you just like it
um how many years have heard of it or
however
um how many here use it
great
awesome
investing is that so the the basic idea
of my script is wouldn't you be cool
for something like this
don't focus on
but if you could just run biking on the
ground and it's easy as that you know
now you can
so we're going to take a look at a
little bit more about home High School
quality is the history architecture
design uh we'll go through a few
examples we are going to go through
examples and demos and use
so as with any piece of technology
Please be aware
the high script is It's Beginning it's
very outlined we're having development
you start using it you try to start
playing around with it expect things to
change
I think this is great
um and luckily with like one of the four
ideas behind it is is actually it's a
big programming fun
again
also this thought is also highly
experimental a lot of Thanksgiving so uh
yeah I'm not
it's not an understatement
so what is my script
is a
framework or a platform
edit in different ways that enables you
to run python those are awesome uh not
only python but large part of the Python
ecosystem on the browser that is powered
by iodide which is a finely dripper on
the Broward based on that assembly uh
it enables you to actually write Python
and JavaScript and make them work
together
um it enables you to Define environments
and manage your environments pretty much
like we would do with
Honda or poetry or other environment or
virtual amp virtual film but also
browser
and it's
designed to be very flexible and uh
plugable
possible more framework I'll talk more
about what what's the difference there
later we'll talk uh but first of all my
high schools well if the reasons I
mentioned earlier are not enough
why not
[Music]
sounds cool
um
so the idea is that we want to make it
we wanted to make it as simple as
possible and what simpler than just
letting me be HTML like you could just
open your editor paste some exit there
and then have fiber running in the
process without allow
uh overhead boilerplate things to make
it work
um we wanted to make
a
production rate so it's a mandatory that
we have we support all ecosystem for
most most of it and we our mission is
bigger than this you know we really want
to make it so that
you know we're gonna break programming
so the 99 of people that are cannot
access it well either through
they are not privileged or because it's
hard to learn program you it's because
it's hard to actually get your programs
to run even if you're learning a
language before you just find them
before you actually can have something
working you need to install python which
is weirdly not trivial I mean
on your machine uh you need to install
your environments
uh even to like we're talking this
is very hard because you have different
platforms and different machines and
dependencies they don't work really well
well the browser is 3D as an Android
and if you could bring pilot to the
browser that would be a
uh relaxator and really we want to make
it friendly and happy we want to get our
resistor getting dirty do weird things
and cooperate with each other and I
think the browser is the first perfect
so we need to get started with
the question lines here
um and that's it or you can download
um the bundle and referencing we do it
the same way
um or the dependencies I actually showed
you the latest how do you start with the
latest version of live play again you
have any options as well as I said
you're gonna create things you're gonna
go fast so because of that we adopted a
system that allows you to reference to
the latest version
Alpha is the one that we announced in
Python uh very happy and even happier
than what it is today and since a lot of
people started using it in a good
experiments we said okay if we should
freeze it so it's always going to be
Alpha so that's the Alpha version
and then we also support unstable which
is basically every time we went to VR we
we release unstable
but use the latest and greatest that's
but also very broken
and then you can always use the invert
people release well we're trying to get
a
kid or something for every month so if
you want if you started developing with
a specific release you can mean that and
make sure that you are you're going to
change we're not going to change
it and you should move always
there's also a lot of support
throughout editors and Ides of starting
doing the great price groups directly at
the code
has a couple of plugins to enabling to
work with all the five strips um
five terminals it as well
but I'll leave my script
well you add those dependencies
of age just through the usual HTML and
then you can't add height and go Within
using the Bison tank this is not
actually the only way
um but this is like a really easy entry
point where you can just drop your plant
into
it it really feels like PHP which is not
really great I know and
usually people are very appreciative of
my own PhD
[Music]
but
we're not joining the dark side
mostly Italian this is very you know
important to me
pineapple it's not
um there's much more really much more
but well we're starter
um
you know you can avoid mixing code with
HTML markup and you just actually I'll
be very honest this is what I would
recommend
[Music]
an easy way for our users to just start
playing with it change code really fast
and all of that but having a micro pilot
in reference there directly it might be
a little more complex
to do but then enables you to do a real
into the best practice it's way easier
to pass your code this way it's easier
to run a lender to reuse all the python
tools that you can use
um it it makes easier also to compose
with modules and you know just a normal
type of programming
um so once we launched in recycle on us
there was a big Trend uh on social media
here actually was one of my major career
of bright highlights a week later I came
home my daughter was
and more than half of those tweets and
oh tick tocks especially or something
about
but oh my gosh it's JavaScript bad or or
funny memes about you know performance
or
um you know in it
in a way that is really not the way we
want to
sell or propose myself in a competitive
way in my mind never mind ice cream is
really additive
so it is not a replacement for
JavaScript it actually is if you're a
JavaScript developer or if you're a
practice developer you should be excited
about it because all of a sudden now
python people can just start using
JavaScript tools that they wanted to use
for years I expect I can think in the
state of this world you can use 33 now
out of the box ease him just works
beautiful visualization
the users can now use an upline Matlock
uh network access sci-fi
[Music]
um
so it's
it's really a win-win you know uh and
part of it is also by Design we want it
to be a framework
and a platform that is written well it
doesn't matter what is written it's
written by Patrick but it's irrelevant
but it makes the two World talk together
well
um
the difference well I'm going to go over
these three Vats because I wanted to
actually control code but talking with
uh Peter Wang who's co-creator of my
script we decided this idea together
arguably
it was in his brain before mine growth
you know
a system on top of plugins is a system
that usually is an indication of
Engineers not knowing what they're doing
right and high school is really happily
designed around plugins so
it doesn't mean we don't know what we're
doing but really this is such a big open
field that we will never really capture
all of users needs all of what you want
to do so we really want to make sure
that you can create
uh applications on top of high school
which makes it a framework
but we want it to be a platform which
basically means you can create
Frameworks on pop-up question
right uh like pretty much like react has
many Frameworks on top of it or you know
you could I don't know using my strip to
create a
a framework that enables you to do
whatever
um
applications or a slideshow like this a
presentation like this
um so as I said work is in progress
things are changing and improving every
day
um some of the features this is a very
professional
architecture of my Hollywood Sports
credits
computer mostly and a little bit for
myself
it's basically a
top layer on top of iPhone and dripper
in this case the default is iodide and
on top of web assembly uh here there's
Instagram
and we want to think of the browser as
this virtual machine that is it
everywhere everything is honestly I
really think that the browser is the new
you know
PPM and
your
home Diner to the doctor to browser like
but also not server-side
um so re comparing really quick with
what's the difference between Vice
script and biodize
um in pi script you would do something
like this you can just use your code you
can focus the stuff you can use JS to
actually communicate with JavaScript and
you can import the thumb yeah yeah yeah
things mostly work a few things don't
really make sense out of the
out of traditional file system basically
in the browser you don't really have uh
access to soft experiences or threat
threads multiple processing uh AC
basically Works a little differently but
we're working also on
solving for those problems as well
so in fire script you would do something
like this
and underneath it's basically called in
biodine for you and and directly with
file that
um the cool thing is that I like Pro
binds a lot of ideas like immediately
available for you even the type of
libraries that have a lot of
dependencies as well
um
sorry let's mentioned also highlight is
is Project emerged from iodine which was
a scientific Computing of the browser
but a lot of
Jupiter notebook bikes and so that is a
great foundation for us to do a live
stream on top of
so in fact like you would do something
like this
load your piadite interpret interpreter
and then you can load your packages
you can also load the install from high
from IDI they're python packages and
then
um and then you just run go this way you
invoke your this
you can go with your python instances
in my script you do your configuration
you know the thing they were calling I
don't think
and it's where you define your
environments uh you can load your
packages pretty much that's just using
your packages
your modules and then once you run the
pi script you just want to go you don't
need to do anything else
we also have another thing in high
script
High rapidly right and actually I think
the rubble well
or an introoper is one of the reasons in
Sweden uh popular we can just hop in and
try stuff out for free but also the
python Community itself and the core
devs are really cool if there are new
things actually I think python is
growing the culin Angus that has an
intra if you type import this in your
in your interpreter it will print out
this which is you know the principles
that I can use uh and you should be
aware of
but in their new cool things we also
think they break those have your whoever
imported into gravity in Python
very beautiful bye you should try and
basically it will pop up this comment
here
which is pretty cool
my script has a similar name basically
you can important anti-gravity
and because we are in the browser
ve actually we can't actually pull stuff
like
actually make it fly
[Music]
so live animation manipulating the SVG
in the dome Direct ly always
and
it's not this one
get some gold right out
if I paste piece of code they just did
some stuff and
preparing about my little objects
there you go it renders on the browser
bearing so you can actually have the
rebel indirectly on the browser
with life
so
let's get into the part of the
the top guys a little bit more less
boring than just be going for
[Music]
um
all right
so and actually this
is
but anyway uh
look at the code
this is example for instance this is
just like a flying uh we're plotting the
correlation between uh wines the line
data sets
um using both a and actually not
volcanoes Seaborn and that positive uh
how this globe looks like
we just have a list of packages
and then your item go and that's really
it that's more than this of course but
there's nothing really more to it
um
every poking
attempts okay so I'll speed up and
actually you have a ton of examples
I'll get to the ones that are cooler so
uh in the past months we've kept seeing
cool things that the community have been
uh you know developing and thinking
about and stuff so I really want to
showcase some of these as well
um
Autumn uh sorry we didn't it was working
on this cool
um
pandas
interactive cheat sheet so you can go
there to the website and actually run by
the road and depending on operation you
can say I don't know I want to learn
about subset roles then you know data
set drop duplicates
it runs directly
and for example the enrolls or you know
I don't know
joined airplanes
and things like this
and he also did another really cool
example
of a date of his cookbook where he put
side-by-side different plotting
libraries and say how would a line chart
using pandas would look like
and this is the result and you can
choose Steve Walker
Plus
and so it really opens up to a lot of
new ideas and you know on the website
you can have running python on the
browser without the servers without
anything it makes development way faster
this tank blocks
a lot
um
all right
Jeff uh glass who actually just became a
high school before developer uh had also
some pretty cool examples who here
um
[Music]
okay so he experimented with app running
uh rich
and actualized basically on
reaches is a CLI type of library on top
of flip that lets you write you know
terminal applications well you can run
that kind of things in the browser as
well which is pretty cool
um Phillip who's works on a lot of his
libraries okay
all of you
scan all that said that has actually
been contributing the typescript a lot
since the beginning and he has all sorts
of cool demos one of them for instance
is act actually running panel on the
browser with a lot of those interactive
examples I will actually show a few
running this is the deck GL one and we
can see it
um
so I can run a game of one who is on the
browser
and that's it
you're going to take control from anyone
else and then just run the route without
having to install anything on the
computer
this one as well
okay
that's where you can have multiple
online
trending with multiple plots on the same
page
um
all right let me see
well also another noun this slideshow
was made with high script
um as a plug-in I actually do plugins I
I had I
there's a markdown plugin that allows
you to create smartphone packs it's high
indeed but you can actually have Mark
markdown code
the code for those slides actually is
here
it's just a text file with a uh HTML and
markdown on your slide and you can see
for instance the markdown
is here
and
um
what I want to show a couple more
examples
there's this one that is using actually
V3 to show some database
on a
food data sets
that sure
um of course with us and Anaconda did to
try it out
um and this one is the Star Wars
visualization on top of the different
data sets showing the connections
between characters and different
episodes
so and this is also using the equipment
Okay so
I also have some exciting news so
um what does it mean basically micro
alliances is pretty much like the PSI
complex
right it is
um
Association that steers
um the the project and creates new
things and we're reinvested it we
grew up you know virtualization and
running things in containers uh and we
think we should contribute to it uh it
is very important to us so we're really
excited about this we are also
working explicitly to increase
both from the point of view of
the
Upstream contributions but also we are
working with the black teams to see how
kind of breaking financially is
important directly you know really as
for highlight but also keep identity or
uh other projects we think that their
success is fine
we read a lot of buyerscriptions here at
Blue Project that helps the community of
python all the browser as a whole and we
are really invested in it and it's also
the default interpreting so
also there's another big new
one of the major creative criticisms on
my script was it's breaking slow you
reason
you know and it's true it is though
because it takes time to run the whole
pythony's river to all the browser
install your dependencies and things
like that
um it is not an easy problem right if
you use bicep or you've seen some of the
examples you have that speeding wheel
that
it's you know it feels to me it feels
like the windows early ages
excuse me so I'm really excited to
show you this
um so we have an experimental branch
with supporting different interpreters
and you have highlight and microphyte
this is the next the first the next one
we're happy and intentionally so so
here's a very trivial hello world in
highlight and this is how long he thinks
and this is how long the microfiber is
it is orders of magnitude master we
measured from 10 to 20 on laptops even
higher on mobile and I actually I'll
show you the link I encourage everyone
to try it out and uh for instance is
just a hello but if I was going to use
numb body
I can run this
from it I will speed up
this is microfiber instantaneous iodine
same day
so this is really exciting
going faster as I said
small it's under it basically create
big other kilobytes and it runs other
minutes uh we're also supporting new
redesigned plugins this
slides are actually
designed plugins to add more features
the project and we also started the
collective project
now it's really hard to decide what you
want to use micro python or highlight I
cannot finish without thinking everyone
that has been supporting the project and
helping a lot of congrats to our new
core depth audio Jeff and all those are
the other card apps telling you Mariana
with Aurora Nicholas also Peter a
co-creator Peter Wilson Phillip at the
honestly helpful but it's more than this
the community as a whole I want to
rethink highlight the wildlife projects
and Michael Roland
enjoy
all the community of Michael and lesson
and everyone here and the whole Bible
community
and
actually praise remember when they can
change the world and we highly encourage
you to put your work on the open and
open towards it
and that's it thank you everyone
[Applause]
um
quick question so is um
supplementary or a work alongside panel
or the two different
great question so question was is live
script supposed to be uh supplementary
or a complimentary to fail or or are
they two different things
highscript is supposed to be the
technology or framework that allows you
to use panel on the browser and panel or
any other hopefully any other python
package that you were using on mobile
and
was the JavaScript ecosystem
as well today now
we really hope that in the future this
is this edition of a new interpreter is
just one step closer to also adding
other names like I personally would love
to see
just being able to run a model in art
and have it with my phone on the browser
on the same page anything that results
in an interesting transfer data and
everything
I think there was some questions
yeah I just question about like
installing the benefits you mentioned
that sometimes it's like officially
slower when you're adding computer
packages each time the bronzer is
refreshed it has to install those
packages that come pipeline or whatever
story they're like smaller versions of
the fact great question so the question
was uh
installing packages is slow
um is because it really that bad or are
there mechanisms to help like hashing or
other things so that you can run things
faster
theory yes and here your browser will
cache
well a lot of what takes time especially
for BioLite is is basically unpacking
and then running the actual last web I
description called basically that should
get patched now there are a few other
things you can there's a way to actually
declare your app as a progressive web
application
that basically will rerun everything for
you and it's already
a mile so it's the same but I don't
think it works for every information
oh that's that's something that we're
actively working as a community not only
in my script but every single project
one Alaska is working on
uh there are a lot of questions there
um a lot of your demos are running code
and Senior results which looks a lot
like Jupiter are the main ways to think
about the difference is that you can
control these interfaces not just that
cells as soon as there's no server
great question
um
the question was a lot of the examples
show
typing and holding and then seeing
results live pretty much like similar to
the Jupiter notebooks
um yes so this is we have that history
very close to the Jupiter Community
right
I was working with a grouper lab team
when we started the project
and including other projects inside
and we think they are very close
together I think the two ecosystems can
benefit from each other a lot a lot of
the the renders that you saw
Applause and other things are actually
sort of borrowed from or is inspired by
the Jupiter project and I think
they took her life as well like he's
using iodide as an over
um I think there are also possibilities
for
in order to use pressure groups vice
versa but one of the we didn't want to
basically
we wanted ice cream to be a little more
free and the raffle is one of those so
you can actually add as many grapples as
you want and feed it as a notebook
basically but you also can also say Okay
I want to have different Rebels on the
page and dive right to the output of
this gravel to another div so you can
actually have more
for free type of
Exploratorium conversation
are not just
that's They Don't Really stay calm with
the format
so one is
um
it's secure
foreign
well the browser itself is a very secure
version like the browser had been uh
doing a lot of jobs a lot of browsers
have done a lot of a lot of work to
isolate and hope your also environments
so you cannot really just access file
system or files or things like this it
runs inside web which is within
but will support it in development and
you also have limited access to things
that they are provided by the girls so
the security aspect of it we are kind of
lucky to rely on what the problem
provides
um
how that relates to data science
basically reproducibility and
of isolation right yeah